paris puis sylvie et agnès cartons sont
ici chez elle
le musée du costume à avallon c'est elle
qui l'ont créée tout a commencé par une
robe d'époque reçu en cadeau
d'anniversaire pour les 12 ans d'agnès
la première d'une collection qui n'a
jamais cessé de s'agrandir
les deux soeurs inséparables ont fini
par décider de les exposer
c'était chez homère ou huit ans et puis
petit à petit ces objets se sont
accumulés et l'accumulation là pas de
chance donc il ya 30 ou 40 ans on a
décidé de créer un premier musée
quelqu'un de dimensions raisonnables
amis en plus tardives on s'était un joli
petit hôtel particulier un des seuls
survivants après les bombardements de
l'agate 40
et puis qu'est ce qui est arrivé on va
continuer à collectionner donc rangé
dans les greniers dans les réserves et
puis plus place donc on a cherché
c'est ainsi que les deux soeurs ont
trouvé cet hôtel particulier de plus de
1000 mètres carrés mis en vente par la
l'île d'avalon une ancienne propriété de
la famille de condé datant du xviiie
siècle qui l'ont fait restaurer
koungou travaux il a fait faire par les
entreprises mais tous nos travaux de
peinture de restauration aérienne
je suis à vos du l'a voulu le véritable
maître d'oeuvre et massot et le
bricolage harkis l'artisan peintre mais
modestement hôtel à rennes quand même de
la personne de chaque année sans l'aide
de personne
les deux soeurs organise une nouvelle
exposition cette année la mode en noir
et blanc de 1770 à nos jours ce sont
elles qui reçoivent et guide les
visiteurs
il y a plus de trois mille costumes aux
réserves donc nous où nous puisons dans
ses réserves
chaque année quelques costumes
correspondant à la thématique l'atonie
des ventes
il faut mettre chaque costume dans un
carton séparés avec du papier de soie ph
neutre
c'est ce qui permet de conserver et puis
à chaque fois on est obligé de faire des
campagnes d'intimité deux fois par an et
puis de toute façon il faut ouvrir les
boîtes où le temps pour être sûr que ça
retire pas de problème
les 12 pièces du musée sont remplies de
mannequins d'un autre temps habillée et
coiffée par les soeurs carton au mur des
portraits qu'elles ont acheté car
personne n'en voulait il n'y a plus de
place mais elle n'arrête pas de faire
des acquisitions
on peut pas s'empêcher de faire de
nouvelles acquisitions et qu'on a vu ce
joli baromètre restauration s'est dit il
va aller parfaitement dans la pièce
simplement après il a fallu chercher
partout à quel endroit
y aurait-il un espace libre mais oui il
suffisait de deux guerriers de le créer
de déplacer un tableau de la gauche vers
la droite
c'est vrai les visiteurs small caps nous
et nous disent vous allez à table le
claf on y lit a pourtant bien un endroit
dont le musée pour ce risque n'existe
pas
si voici à la chapelle nous avons eu la
surprise de retrouver au premier étage à
tous de la pente de la rue est en fait
il y un dénivelé de près de 2 mètres 70
entre l'entrée par laquelle nous sommes
entrés et la chapelle qui se trouvent
ici l extrémité du bâtiment à niasse et
sylvie carton vous attendent du 15 avril
au 1er novembre
chaque année elle accueille trois à
quatre mille visiteurs